en france andré girons le ministre de la
défense vient d'adresser ses compliments
à la société beso pour la réussite du
premier vol d'essai du rafale vous le
disions hier soir le nouvel avion
prototype a volé pendant une heure au
départ d'istres dans lés bouches du
rhône la mise au point du rafale est en
avance de 6 mois sur son calendrier ce
n'est pas sans importance puisqu'il est
en concurrence directe avec le futur
avion de combat européen
pierre babey altitude 10 mille huit
cents mètres vitesse mach 1,3
c'est-à-dire 1400 kilomètres heure pour
son premier vol le rafale n'a pas lésiné
sur les performances aux autres vols
expérimentaux bien sûr le soin de tester
les capacités ultime de la machine mais
le rafale en plein ciel c'est d'abord un
bep aile delta empennage canard entrées
d'air celui ventrale tout ou presque est
original dans le dessein du 92e
prototype signé dassault 7 actuellement
l'avion de combat le plus avancé du
monde entier mais il faudra que ce petit
génie aéronautique réussissant
l'atterrissage commercial après les
déconvenues de l'avion de combat
européen l'assombrissement des
perspectives de coopération militaire du
ciel il lui faudra trouver les amateurs
en dehors de nous armer et de nos
frontières quatre pays européens
seraient d'ores et déjà intéressés